what's up buzzer welcome back to another
episode of safe pack the fractured but
whole let's continue playing everybody
let's go oh oh the support just rip into
Nintendo someone get polygon this is
outrageous
real the [ __ ] you're singing mean ah he
can pass me anyway oh excuse me I was
actually a miss click a miss fart
where is scrambles we're real close I
can feel it I know who is that well I
should be easy he has a drum that was a
drone controller it's not a drunk
disappointed alright we're gonna defeat
general disarray that should be easy
let's do this how much Lego can you have
dude like that's a lot of Lego let's get
really alright - in with the Cure gain
[Music]
the dialogue is so buggy like it clearly
said get queuing there but it actually
say oh yeah he has a weird one that goes
like diagonally and see if we can hit
more than No
okay well I guess this is the attack
we're doing now so this will probably do
do more damage right because it'll push
him back to Cartman
card enabled pushing back nice they have
mecha minions great yes
oh wow is he standing in the lava
vamonos mecha minion wow they got the
technology straight from Japan who would
at that okay
yeah old
bring it mr. Hayes almost then my god
how many minutes does he have my god
Mexicans everywhere he might be able to
finish him yeah that one does a lot of
damage that was that we just had to take
out the general okay nice that's what I
always say ignore the Mexicans and take
out the general hey we've got an epic
sign yeah man that is great I feel
really good about this one oh wow
oh no this is love everywhere now no no
no I'm already dead okay we're gonna
find a way to save you do something to
it yet there's nothing here my sand
blaster needs compressed hair to work
it's the one from the entrance the gates
landing lunch not remember it's okay
guys we all knew when we signed on to be
[ __ ] friends that it might end like this
stay calm super Craig we're gonna get
you home sorry dude but it looks like
this was a one-way trip No
[Music]
I'm starting with Everett things like
that
we found a match what are you doing are
you crazy do you know what kind of
firepower someone would need to make
that work ah don't underestimate my
power
don't underestimate a man that's is a
super Craig I had to stabilize you are
you serious right now
kill me look [ __ ] did you get that
Carmen online super Craig just stay
still you suffered a lot you guys go
ahead I'm gonna just try and stabilize
him really cool back there now we can
clear love it whenever we want we make a
great team but Lord all right so we
unlocked and you bought a buddy power by
the power of shoving tubes in our butt
bit okay all right I guess I'll go here
there's probably will be something up no
never mind I can't walk
[Music]
I'm so sick of the lava I I agree 100%
we can break this maybe you're liable
for any property damage all right we can
use our body power and a wine when he'll
read Kyle when clearly this one's easy
they sure love fart jokes in the Sun but
they sure do
well we have this over here right but
then what I have to be up there it's to
jump down isn't it have I lost all hub
well we have one more you just dying how
oh yes of course
ha ha ok all right ok ok I read again
yeah yeah all right let's take off buddy
hardcore miss tan
someone told me also that you make more
money oh my god it's so beautiful if
you're white in the game I don't know if
that's true all right I guess you left
us huh
we got a pack of ramen which you can't
see because I'm covering this screen
with my beautiful face where to now
actually there's some more stuff behind
here why not why not we got some BG
balls whatever that is and some more
china plates great love our outfit
though love love love it looks like
we're gonna have to use says Sam's power
here yeah no I know and he's got a fart
on it you gotta fought on the lava thank
you
nice one all right let's keep going but
Lord it's a really good game mechanic
that I really enjoy him
Edgar salute Edgar what the heck man I
need to stop calling out stuff that you
guys clearly can't even see but you know
you got to keep loading me should we
attack these guys are sneaky I ran I
feel like we're gonna have to fight him
right now okay we can just I can hear
cats they must be any final oh that's
some real high-grade [ __ ] there cat like
that would go to the boss man himself
you idiots you don't talk about him now
we gotta kill these shits okay I'm down
to kill them so there was one episode I
remember the long ago where people would
take the cat urine and to get higher or
whatever I don't know what to do with
the kun kun is so useless
so stop here somebody's about to get
fixed who's it gonna be this one might
do it No
all right hit him oh [ __ ] the barrels
gonna explode ah damn it's gonna explode
on us though shoes ok well at least now
we know maybe we can use the laser here
yeah let's do it
perfect it's gonna blow
look at that they can heal because they
have drugs Hey Oh oh wow
not really we're actually you're doing
pretty well that ok we have a combat
buddy what is that ok all right what can
call girls do then huh blow up
individual that's pretty good are you
texting the barrel
nice Oh another one
they're all gonna blow it's a chain
effect
nice very nice and here we go
nailed it what is in the back with the
cans man Jesus
all right that's not very Christian man
I don't know what to tell you we just
put the cat urine in the drug the hem
yeah it's like it's like he wants more
crime in the streets professor ko no no
way no spooky man we got to do this if
they tell us don't you get it what a way
to go not a bad way to go
nice and here we go okay I'm ready or do
we have to use her the password is 0 1 2
3 uncrackable uncrackable code luckily
I'm a crack master I mean I guess I
didn't do it right
okay let's try using the butthole in the
thing they're happy about that okay
alright that's interesting you're not a
bad to beat so happy got'em combat
advantage baby look at that [ __ ] no
other youtuber could do that that takes
skill takes years of crayon my god that
was beautiful Garrett Gayo Gayo rat okay
you come in here voice
go tell everyone you cut yourself
manscaping and it's cute tan hell yes
I mean God Church yes we did it
I'm glad that thing broke I was like
should I shoot her or not but where is
he he got away
we gotta use flip what is that anyway we
gotta use said the butthole thing oh my
god if someone alright put that one
there and then when this was a little
trickier
hell yes indeed stain let's go
my face is literally inside his butt oh
wow they got a yes seriously that's a
lot of love a man why do I say lava it's
Lego it's lenka oh my god what is Oh
what you mean mecha mexican minion care
to play
okay let's do this one we got a pretty
strong lineup so I like how one guy is
just literally his crotch look at the
guy in the crotch oh my god
okay we got it move up oh wow his
shootings from there huh well you know
that's a microaggression they're saying
extra spicy just because you're Mexican
[ __ ] I'm burning
[Music]
we're just gonna use these I made a ton
of them anyway
congratulations oh you had to do
how do I shoot him that hits him okay on
ice should probably like split up oh
[Music]
that was nice
all those fireworks no no no no no no
not Sam damn it what in that what I'm
burning now damn it
ah cuz you're just walking across
whatever just take it
[Music]
get caned okay I know it's gonna be a
second you know it's gonna be what is he
saying
get the [ __ ] med by yeah phase two
[Music]
let's go oh they're gonna heal them
we're gonna have to take out the yeah
they're gonna here like dammit I could
just use the old and kill all of them
let's do it it's the quickest way
[Music]
but we're gonna have to know I'm
actually impressed
I totally smell like a king wait we
can't actually attack there what how do
i attack him then there's no no no no no
no no no you bet no finish him finish
him thank you
no whaling on my watch so dog in there
oh my god that's another face there's a
third face everyone shut up I think we
can finish him
I'm done done easy miss demon what up
look at that XP look at it go up just
like my ding-a-ling very nice very nice
yeah money well spent but it was great
working with you again man yeah well I
told you this was a one-shot deal
come on shed come back to the can't do
that kite freedom pals is gonna make way
more money with their franchise you're
wrong we're gonna make like a billion
dollars we're gonna make like a billion
we're back at headquarters who could it
be
maybe it's that Tommy nothing kid he's
always been kind of a dick have a seat
Thundercats
are you just at this is that a key
cartridge that's kind of cool
it doesn't cost much a recipes
okay why not no I'm not gonna join them
yeah that's pretty cool why not why not
[Music]
oh my god
could it be no it's impossible no it is
possible there's only one person I know
of who can disguise himself so easily
and it's the same person who might have
a motive for tearing South Park apart Oh
Mitch Conner what wait sorry when his
cover was blown he was arrested by the
police but escaped but why would he want
to take down that pie and where would he
get all his money shut up it's not
registered with [ __ ] Connor I'll be
you know know Kylie's right you guys it
couldn't be Mitch Connor Connor died in
an oil rig explosion in northern Alaska
[ __ ] this I'm going to bed
yes yes good idea hear me cut everyone
get back to your homes it's getting late
let's all reconvene tomorrow after and
now the news program that starts your
day off right good morning South Park
the South Park vigilante struck again
last night this time at a meth lab in
the downtown new storage facility here
with more is a [ __ ] in a fedora table
six men were arrested last night after
the vigilante exposed a huge meth lab in
the storage facility behind me
eyewitnesses have come forward with
shocking reports that the vigilantes
parts were so awful they seemed to
actually rip the fabric of time you
ain't never heard a fart like this man
he was like one minute he farted on my
dick you're the next thing my dick was
like 20 seconds in the path whoa finally
someone is standing up to all the crime
in this city if you ask me these people
here all deserve to be farted on he's a
menace if you asked me how long before
this vigilante gets radical and blows up
a school or a church huh how long before
Captain America becomes captain ideology
the third Captain America movie how long
was that about six years about six years
dozens of protesters gathered outside
the police station today as a warrant
was issued for the vigilantes arrest
[Applause]
Crusaders and sneak around and fart on
people at night we urge all citizens to
arm themselves and fight against this
kind of rectal the pressure
[Applause]
rectal oppression I've never thought I
heard those words yeah it's me
nobody knows anything about this kid not
what race it is again if it's a boy or a
girl what do we do so are they talking
about a house just keep getting the
product into people's drugs and alcohol
I'll handle the vigilantes are you Seri
thing out of control you said you could
get the mayor out of office you wanted
to be left alone commissioner doing I've
made that happen just stay calm and soon
everyone will have exactly what they
read
that's sewed up yes my name is Wendy
nice to have you at our school hmm
that little girl told you about it's a
lot worse the Chamber of Commerce wants
to get rid of the Vigilant oh no matter
what it takes
you know the bathrooms in the park Paul
girl wants you to meet her there right
now okay
[Music]
let me just read transform here wow that
was so cool wasn't he stop don't judge
me
don't judge me just butter out a
different clothes came on that it shut
up I look cool a gala cool get real I
look cool alright well let's tell it
transport it's now five to nine the
password can you be at two places at
once right
need to get somewhere soda sob that's at
the end of the shoes we're gonna have to
walk I love that episode so funny
anyway Alyssa's walk there this is it
yeah yeah this is it where we see though
meet me and they start soda SOPA in the
space formerly occupied by steed we
needs an incense
I'm buddies still have willing to help
at least I mean he doesn't want to shove
up a long in someone's dong you know we
did indeed goodbye
legend all right this is Kenny's house
that's not it
[Music]
hey they got it in Brighton oh there's
the steed I saw it now okay this is it
I guess we're meeting the king Paine
looking for answers
yes mr. Connor sends his regards he
wanted to come himself but he's a very
busy man he mentioned some horrible
tragedy happened to your mother
funny how a few moments in our lives can
completely change who we are and now
you're gonna be taken out by assassins
known as the city ninja service it was a
drag of course the city ninjas you know
what to do with them when you're done
after it's done you'll pay your badge
back up that's on the website
you don't sound Japanese you sure you're
really ninjas just get it over with
[ __ ] in your service you want to I
don't have five thousand in business
money for bribes so we still have to
murder you sorry okay all right Oh they
join me even what the heck
all right well I guess we have to kill
them
minja stop so what they're Korean what
should we attack win [ __ ] is actually
getting better he's not that bad wait
they're Korean what the heck definitely
got that wrong finish him nice no more
what the heck I wasn't ready for that
all right whatever
what does more are you kidding me okay
one of them is down yes yes nice the
white ninjas are dead
yes we're on a roll come on baby
yeah he's dead it's fine seriously now
super Craig I doubt it okay here we go
wait I've never seen super Craig's yes
oh my god that's my new favorite what I
can't let's finish this oh and there it
is that was hard that was really
difficult
yeah damn boring stupid idiot shitty
aeneas alright what do we get I guess so
and now we're alone again that doesn't
really make any sense for the plot I
thought this would be a solo fight
member by member of Isis I get down from
here a matter of days okay
No how'd I even get up here
oh I know from here what Oh
alright now we go back to Coons lair
okay hello kid known as butthole you got
lucky one time but CD she didn't heed me
a lurking shadow no no oh man okay all
right okay we're gonna have to watch out
for them now goddamn shitty ninjas let's
go to the Kuhn layer and pretend nothing
happened
nothing at out nothin eddo no girls
allowed okay okay will do
after I end this episode thank you guys
so much for watching another one really
loved it recording these all the support
as always I know I keep saying it but
appreciate you guys squad for him